people
okay
I'm very pleased you're welcome Dr
Robert Jackson and oh
yes
oh yeah
okay yeah so and then I've brought our
speaker today Dr Robert Jackson he is a
passionate atmospheric scientist and
software engineer who has either LED or
co-developer on multiple open source
software projects for atmospheric data
analysis in addition he uses data
science tools and machine learning to
gain Insight from multi-terabyte climate
climate data sets
um and then also we are here today at
the dpdi
yeah DPI sorry
um and then here I'll give it to our
host Sandra
thank you so much and it's our pleasure
to have you here I'm Sandra giving I'm
one also see in your research scientist
at the discovery Partners Institute here
in Chicago that is DPI
and it has 3D Partners also all over
mission is to jump to start people's
Tech careers and companies and startups
in Chicago and the Chicago area Illinois
and the three departments where I'm from
applied r d so we do scientific research
I have brought my own research to DPI
and that the science gateways
distributed computing usability research
software sustainability of research
software
and we have two other departments who
are very into Workforce Development of
connections from really K-12 school
systems to to colleges to universities
really to go the whole way through for
the education part and with that it's my
pleasure to give it to our speaker
and I guess I'm also the microphone
I think we've got a good set to be
recorded
everyone said name is Bobby Jackson from
Argonne National Lab and today I'm going
to be talking to you about a python
about a python package that one can use
to do what we call multi-gil Operator
retrievals of wins from radar networks
so essentially what what the problem
we're trying to solve here is we've got
we've got radar networks that are
present all over the us including the
Next Rad Network that many of the people
here in fact most people here probably
looked at an image of a radar screen we
were like trying to look to see how we
get wins from those
and in particular I would like to first
thank my collaborators here listed on
the screen for other contributions to
this work
there we go
and now that we can see the screen up
here I'd also like to I also like to
thank Pi data Chicago and the discovery
Partners Institute for hosting the space
to be able to be able to give this talk
as well as the uh Duo Department of
Energy's uh climate model development
validation activity for funding the work
on this as well as the Argonne
laboratory directed research and
development Expedition Expedition
program
so how do we measure winds so there are
many ways that we measure wind in the
atmosphere so one of the ways we do it
is through quite measurements for Mana
monitors and aircraft so these provide
very accurate information about wins in
the 2D space an anemometer and actually
you can even get to 3D Woods to man
monitor as well as the aircraft from a
single point
however the drawback of this is that
this is only over a single point value
so you lack a lot of information about
the structure of these clouds in
addition we also have we also get it
from weather balloon so there's a
picture of me actually watching a
weather balloon for a uh NSF field
project back in 2009 where we sample
winter storms called plows
and also for radar with profilers that
provide
they will provide a very vertical
profile of the Winds but they're
accurate to the meter scale resolution
but the only provide what we call solo
straw view of the storm to the columns
so we only are getting one little piece
of the storm you're not getting the full
3d picture of that that's what we bring
in
our regular Network such as what the
United States that Noah Noah has called
the next red radar Network almost
everybody here has looked at the images
from this radar it is what uh it is what
tells us whether there's a storm coming
and it covers about 80 percent of the
United States it turns it it's in terms
of coverage and it covers altitudes for
about zero kilometers up to about 15
kilometers over the atmosphere so it
gives us much wider spatial coverage of
these radar Networks
and what these Radars do is that they it
made a beam a microwave radiation and
record back the amplitude and phase of
the back scattered microwaves as they
spin around it as it gets so what the
next rides in particular will do what we
call play position indicator scans where
they will do us they will spin in a 360
degree as a view with over one elevation
they'll go up to another elevation and
then repeat the 360 degree as a new
until you cover about 10 to 15
elevations dependent on what your uh
depending on what weather is present in
the area the National Weather Service
actually changes what this what this
volume pattern is
but then it wasn't that these objects
such as rain hail and birds and plagues
and insects and smoke all reflect
radiation back to the radar and it all
can be detected by it by it what we're
interested in more is precipitation so
we apply some quality control algorithms
to remove what we call the non-hydram
meteors or what anything that isn't rain
snow grapple or hail anything we're not
interested in an example of a example of
some of this radar image is shown on the
right we have an example cell that
passed over the Houston area here
during uh one of our uh during one of
our build experiments out that are at
the uh do we recently did over the over
the over Houston what we see here is a
thunderstorm that forms in the early
morning hours it lasts for about 45
minutes to an hour going to the north
over Galveston Bay and proceeding to the
east of the East area
now one of the tricks about getting wins
in particular from the radar is that the
Doppler radar the Doppler radar will
record the velocity of particles in the
direction in and out of the beam it
doesn't actually give you one of the
disadvantages of the radar is that why
you get the full volume coverage you
only get the wind in one direct in the
direction that is to the beam and it's
determined by the dot by the dot was
shift of the wave that comes in so it
just records the difference in Phase
between the in-going wave and the
outgoing wave and if this phase shift is
greater than one wavelength then the
radar will record a negative shift and a
negative velocity even of course the
velocity to flip sign and if the
velocity which just happened is called
Nyquist velocity so we have to correct
for all of these different uh aspects of
the Doppler velocity as well for example
here
we have a storm coming through and we
have a we have an a radar image of a of
a storm coming through where we could
see the Doppler velocity
inbound going from 15 to minus 15. that
is literally just an artifact of the
radar we have to clean up with
and you can see it here where we apply
these Corrections and then now we're
able to get 20 meters per second
velocities like it's properly recorded
and we do this with tools such as the
Pion arm radar toolkit where by called
Pi art and this is a that's like this is
a toolkit that is developed by our group
here at Argonne that is used for a
variety of tests for basic plot a to
more complex processing pipelines and it
can radar rewrite our data in a variety
of formats create plots and
visualizations and correct and do
corrections on the radar data as well as
writing radar data into a common into
the commonly used data format and the
atmospheric side this is a geoscience is
called netcdf
so first what I'm going to do is I'm
actually going to give a little bit of
an introduction to the before I go to Pi
DDA I'm going to go with the
introduction of about Pi art and this is
available through a product through an
ed car unit data and University of
albany-led project called project pythia
where there their mission is provided
public they basically accessible trading
resources for anybody will wanting to
use Earth do earth science with a
Scientific Python ecosystem and it makes
sense of the huge volumes of data so if
we actually go here and click on the
write our cookbook
this will actually this whole page here
will show here various examples of how
to use the pyre toolkit to view your
radar data as well as go over the basics
of fundamental basics of weather radar
that anybody could come here to read at
any time and then see it and see what we
hear what we have here so first I'm
going to go here
and I'm going to
actually what I'm gonna do is go
to the Raider cookbook
yeah I'm gonna
have these same slides present in
another tab
so we are giving so this is get when I'm
slides I'll be presenting here I'm going
to show here a little later about a
short course that we're actually giving
next week at Minneapolis at the American
immunological society's radar conference
but those shows this is gonna this shows
here is a cookbook and how to use this
pie art package to visualize your radar
data and the freeway it Associated the
different prerequisites that into
different packages as far as the basics
of a Carta pie for visual visualizing on
maps and well-known packages within the
pi data Community such as matplotlib and
numpy
so first we have here are Imports that
we have here
no so we do our proper Imports and this
in this cookbook has all of the
different packages already installed and
you can run it from the web anytime you
want here
we do the Imports and what is priority
over what pirate is able to do
is an open source package for viewing
radar data that anybody could if anybody
with an anaconda could go ahead and
install and do a con install and then
run on their own in their own
environment
so the rated data we just use a function
cup higher.io.read and what this does is
that it reads a variety of radar formats
so these are different formats that the
radar Community has used over the years
higher we're actually trying to make
their job easier and try to
automatically detect this format for you
so that you could go ahead and read the
file so we have an example file from the
University of Alabama huntsville's armor
radar that it's going to try and read in
here and it does here successfully by
just using prior to io.read
now if we look at the Raider object it
stores the radar the fields that are in
the radar or the variables that it
stores within these keys so we know here
that this radar Story the total power
the reflectivity which is the
reflectivity map that you see on your
when you when you look at the look at
the radar velocity which is going to be
the wind direction here as well as
various other polarization
characteristics of the radar that I
won't have time to go into today
so here we look at the reflectivity
that's stored as a mass array in the
date in the data key of this
reflectivity structure if we look at the
shape
it's it's the number of rays and the
number basically what we have is the
number of rays that are sent out by the
right are being in one scan
versus the number of Gates or the number
of uh pulses that are out for every
radar scan
so there's a number of gates in the war
basically tells you the distance for the
radar or what we call the range for the
radar
so we're going to look at the 300 Ray in
the second gate
we can just look at that and say it's
minus 4.5
but at a big the coolest thing about
this is that we can visually visualize
these results using the graph radar map
display object
and then we just do display plot PPI map
so what this is a plot the radar image
of the lowest level for you
and give it a second so this shows you a
thunderstorm that's being scanned by the
armor radar as we can see over here
we have some thunderstorms on the
Leading Edge over here and then another
line here right behind it so this is
able to quickly make these
visualizations here for you for radar
data if you wanted to grab from Nexrad
or if you wanted to grab from any sort
of other radar Source this could do it
within just a couple lines of code
in default it's going to plot the
default was the lowest elevation scan
and it also set these color bars over
range from -30 to 70. so let's go and we
could go in and adjust these properties
by doing let's say the third elevation
scan as well as setting the color bar
limits from minus 20 to 60 but it just
suggested the B Min V Max and sweep
and now we can see that the color bars
represent the range of values that are
seen just a little bit better
and now we can change the color bar to
something different
and here is the pot here we have here
the pi art image Empire package here for
the carbon color map well we can see
that it's distinguishing what we have in
here is clutter and Noise
yeah probably some of the nearby trees
versus the storms and precipitation out
here in the greens and reds
and there are different examples to
where we could View
different elevations
or a different field so with the
cross-correlation ratio is is that the
radar will record back whatever it sends
out the weight it sends it into two
polarizations a horizontally polarized
light and vertically portalized light
anyway chloride back to pulses in both
of those polarizations and what this
tells you is how correlated the
horizontal and vertical polarizations
are in a return signature so for Spears
they scatter both of these polarizations
at about the same at about the same
intensity so we expect this correlation
coefficient to be around one so here we
should see mainly raindrops present here
as we go into the volume along with the
correlation coefficients around one so
in summary within this notebook we
covered some of the basics of working
with radar data now I'm going to get it
to a little bit more of the weeds here
and get into what I've here came here to
present today about Pi DDA
so as I told as I mentioned earlier how
do we retrieve wins from these net radar
networks so we have a network of Radars
and they only retrieve the velocity of
scatters in the direction of the beam so
for 3D wins we need info from the others
from other sensors and models and
physical constraints with different
spatial typical coverage and resolution
how do we integrate this information
together to make such a retrieval
so here we do this using What's called
the 3D variational technique and we
commonly and that's what what's commonly
used in the field so we find the winds
the for the horizontal components in the
vertical component that minimizes cost
function
such that the uh the estimated wind
speed for the radar and the retrieved
winds is minimized and that we also
satisfy physics such as the mass
continuity and vorticity equation and
each one of these constraints has
adjustable weights that determine what
what level you want to give how much how
much weight you want to give to that
constraint now for all this you also
need to have an initial state to work
upon for the variation of work now the
implementation of this code is done in a
call what's called python Dual Doppler
analysis of Pi DDA and it's an open
source implementation of this 3D VAR
retrieval that you could do you could
retrieve woods from an arbitrary number
of Radars it's built upon the pi art
package that I showed earlier and it's
available on content Forge compatible
with python 3.8 plus and if you have
either tits or flow or GX installed you
can use it will be able to Leverage The
gpus that are present on your machine
then here's an example of some of the
width of a win retrieval that you can do
using what what it using a constraint
called the high resolution Rapid Repair
what this is It's a forecast model
the National Weather Service uses to
predict storms within the next 12 hours
or so
and it's done at about it's basically
it's a weather forecasting model it's
one in about three kilometers resolution
and it's run every hour and it adjusts
in the current radar observations to try
to make this forecast
in addition we have two Radars present
here and this is over the course of
North Carolina one over here one over
one over here over LTX and then the mhx
radar coming down here so what we are
showing here are the winds with the
estimated rainfall overlay over the rest
of the radar estimated rainfall rates
and these wood Contours represent
whether we're in gale force or storm
force winds with red being
with red big gale force and the storm
being in their blue big storm force
winds and what we can see here is that
uh Pi DDA is able to resolve some of
these uh localized the winds and these
localized bands that are coming in
through hurricane Florence as it
approaches into as it approaches into
North Carolina
so I want to move over next to the
example notebook well I have available
so what I will go here
to escape
go back
hmm
oh no
I gave somebody a heart attack
suppose now for the main event here well
listen look so Pi ddas it's the open
source package for achieving wins for
multiple popular analyzes so you got to
use the 3D it's a 3D variational
technique and then here I summarize
again with the variational technique
corresponds to for your Winfield
it does it by minimizing this cost
function related to these various
constraints that I mentioned earlier the
first in order to get Pi DDA would
import the necessary libraries
to give it a year a minute
and then as I'll go ahead and uploaded
Pi DDA so for this case study we'll
examine we're going to actually look at
a case of Northern Alabama that's what
we had a what we call metal scale
connective system or bus that people may
call it's a line of thunderstorms with
supercells out ahead of the main line
approaching the Huntsville Alabama
region so we're going to look at this
case for uh we're going to be able to
look and see how Pi DDA is able to well
some of the updrafts some of the
updrafts that are in this storm as well
as some of the structure of the winds
that we have so first we'll load our
date our armor data
and then here's what we'll do
we'll do something called well earlier
what I've mentioned we have to do is
called the aliasing the radar data now
what pyre has is a function and it has
an algorithm in here to do the correct
the deal is a correction that I had
shown earlier called the Alias region
based so we're going to use this snippet
of code here to do the to go ahead and
do this dlac correction within just a
couple of lines of code just to ensure
that our popular velocities are
representative of the structure of the
storm that we have and that we don't
have these aliasing artifacts affecting
our wind input winds
so now we want to just quickly give a
Sandy check for our data and here we
have the data from the armor radar being
plotted over here with the supercells
out ahead of it here and then the line
of thunderstorms right behind it
we also looked at corrective velocity
values
and here we can see that we don't have
that we that we don't have these uh what
we have here are more smooth transitions
within the Doppler velocity where we
expected upper velocity because of the
direction of the Winds to shift or
smoothly from about minus 30 to 30. we
still have a little aliasing over here
but we're only going to be retrieving
the winds from inside this box over here
so I'm not as concerned about potential
artifacts from this radar over here but
we have done it that's the cleaning up
of the wind radar data here just using
some of the one past daily step
and then now we're going to go go and
remove some of these other Speckles over
here including these these these noise
artifacts in clutter by using the D
speckle function and that makes this
cleaned up even more where now we have
probably the most amount of these
artifacts and the radar data removed
that we can have
next what we have to do is to take that
radar data and what the radar records it
records the data in its native quarter
that's so records it in antenna
coordinates we have to converge it to a
Cartesian grid
so what we're going to do here
is we're going to high art has routines
for doing this too called map grid from
Radars it will take this radar object
and it will make a grid I will put it in
a Cartesian grid so that we could do
easier analysis with the radar data
rather than at its radar native
coordinates
so this will go ahead and make that grid
and it will convert it to
an x-ray object an x-ray here it's a
record expects to raise that package for
reading in that CDF data then the X-ray
data set contains all the dimensions
coordinates as well as your different
data variables with the different 3D
with the difference of Dimensions that
are in metadata that are in them so this
here is showing that the grid here has
some of our differential phase expected
what a corrective velocity values and we
can actually use x array even to do
plotting of the data at these different
levels by just doing data set I sell
that reflectivity in this case Dot Plot
and then here we have here
that same we we know the gridding we
still see the same structure the storms
at the 500 meter large and if we go
at the 115 so we're looking here at a
cross section to the storm we can see a
vertical cross section of the gridding
where we and it looks here we have a
fairly reasonable structure integrating
where we don't have a lot of
discontinuities in the radar data one of
the things you have to watch out for
when doing this is you can get different
you can get the radar data gets more
sparse as you get further up so you have
to be make sure you have a continuous
grid when you're doing some of these
retrievals next we can load the next red
data and this is available on Amazon web
services under the NOAA next grade level
two bucket so you can actually just use
the uh you can actually go ahead and
just use as you've got an unload it
right off of S3 and download the next
rat data and they have all of the next
right data for every radar that's ever
been that's ever been stored that's ever
been done since 1992 was when the next
ride right or network started and that's
all stored on Amazon S3 so we could
actually hire has native functionality
to be able to load from S3
that
and we'll look at the seventh file over
here
at this time step and it will just load
that file right from the S3 bucket
so this is the second radar we're
looking at this is just the NOAA weather
radar for the state time period and we
can visualize these storms over here
again and another view of these as we
come through now the next level two data
also need to be dlas as well so we do
some of the same corrections to that
data we've done before
we'll go here
and we'll visualize the grids that come
out of that
corrective velocity
and this looks like a delay corrective
velocity you can go back
now the next step after we get our data
prepared for the variational retrieval
we now have to have initial guess of the
wind field the cost function
minimization so Pi DDA has support for
various initializations including
weather balloon data or even model data
such as wurf or other warcast models to
where you could go in and put in a model
but go ahead and play one of these for
your initial stage in this notebook I'm
going to use a white right side a
weather balloon launch where we have
weather balloon data that is what that
was done the more just a few hours
beforehand to get the initial wind field
it'll give us initial guess for our very
initial retrieval so this code here will
load in your wind data as present and
then we use make Winfield for profile to
make the initial guess
and then the core function here is done
using retrieval.getd Winfield and as
many potential keyboard inputs that you
could customize here including including
all your weights and all your initial
wind fields that you apply you could do
different filtering and even
do different engines for doing the data
now what I'm going to do here
however do here I've actually this step
here will probably take about 15 to 20
minutes so thankfully what I've done is
I've went ahead and reloaded pre-loaded
the data
that was the result of this retrieval so
that I'm not taking all the time here to
go ahead and just do the retrieval while
I'm spending here talking so ydda also
has a visualization routines here where
we can look at the horizontal cross
section
for example through a quiver plot
and we could do different type of
streamline plots bar plots and we could
go through a quiver plot of this storm
by just doing horizontal cross-section
quiver and then here we can see winds
flowing to the Northeast now what these
lobes here are what I call the Dual
topper lobes though we get the best data
quality if we have the radar beads that
are perpendicular to each other so in
these later lobes the radar beams are
specifically perpendicular to each other
so that we have so we could have what
component of the wood field measure to
this measure it over here and then and
then it's perpendicular component
measured at that same point so the
therefore we therefore we're able to get
more of a two to three D view of the
Wind
so what we have here are winds flowing
to the Northeast and what these Contours
represent are where updrafts are present
so we could see up we could see that
it's resolving some of the updrafts that
are going to that are forming some of
these that are forming these storms as
we go through including this updraft
confirming is here to Kitty so probably
some new formation out ahead of a
supercell that we wouldn't be able to
see yet with just the radar with just
the reflectivity alone
in addition we'll also look at some uh
waiver plots from a cross section and
you could see if resolving the updrafts
going through here at around 10 to 12
meters per second that are that are dead
that are then uh just preceding
preceding the downdrafts that are that
are then forming the storm or we can
view a horizontal cross-section here
with wind barbs and what this shows us
over here
are some of the issues us here are the
updrafts that are presents over here
with winds coming from the southeast
so what did I
what else did I have here today so I
think
from here one another thing I wanted to
show today
in particular this is a part of tools
that are uh part of the what we call the
open radar Science community and we have
a main web page for this called open
radarscience.org
yeah as they copy
and I will go ahead and
so what does this is a community
platformed open source weather radar
software so there's all these different
projects that are part of the open radar
Science stack including up high art
well man there's this is another radar
processing package called bolt rad we
also have the pi rad package here
disease all these are different tools
that you could use to process your
weather radar data that are all
available on the open source rate open
source uh open writer sites website
in addition we've had various workshops
where you could view various tutorials
that we presented including one we
presented last year done in the Cardinal
Switzerland Florida is part of the e-rad
2022 open short course all the different
uh tutorials that we are here available
online if you want to get familiar with
the different radar packages
and how to use them and offer all these
tutorials
and we'll have the AMS we'll have the
one I show you for AMS 2023 uploaded
probably very
probably very soon in fact I could give
the I could post a link in the zoom to
it right now but if you go here we you
can launch a Docker container here that
will actually go a binder that will go
ahead and
load the environment for you and then
once you're able to load up this
environment then you can execute the
Jupiter notebooks on the cloud and be
able to learn how to use some of these
packages as on their own as you as you
go ahead and start learning about how to
process your weather radar data
so another another uh resource I want to
go to is to open radar science.discourse
and what we have here is so this is a
discourse Forum where anybody can
anybody who's using any of these open
Raider sites tools can ask questions and
then those of us who are part of the
open radar Community can help answer
them and try to help you get you on your
way to uh analyzing your radar data so I
would encourage if you ever to want to
use the open source writer tool stack to
join the discourse group where we and
come introduce yourself and meet us and
uh don't be afraid to ask questions and
I think that will be if anybody has any
questions I think that's what I had for
today and I'd like to thank everybody
for attending the talk
University
I will say what I've analyzed for a
similar radar so we had to see band
polarization radar in Darwin Australia
it took data from 1998 to
2015 and that took 27 terabytes
yeah
so if I mentioned the Next Rad data is
probably I would have to guess it's on
an order since it's for
that's this since it's for probably a
hundred Radars across the United States
we were probably talking pedascale
well right now with that all that data
is on Amazon S3
yeah it's on AWS yeah all the next we're
at level 2 Data is on AWS
Market what
yeah
we yes we have a
yes so we have actually have started to
embrace python as a standard language
over the past 10 years we've seen a
pretty big increase in the use of python
and up to the point where it has its own
conference at the AMS annual meeting on
how to use Python for atmospheric
applications and even it has a Sci-Fi
track as well so
and there was a question online that I
saw
it was how the radar was collected
yeah
so as as far as how do we so how do we
ensure if the methodology is correct so
we have a lot of times we'll do wait
sometimes we can verify with the rate or
wind profiler and do a compares to the
vertical velocities against the Raider
wind profiler another way to to just
validate is to use what we call uh
up oh it's called it's got observing
system simulation experiments we take a
model you take a model simulation you
simulate a radar inside and then you
actually perform the retrieval on the
model simulated radar and it can pair
back against the model winds
so it's like you're actually the model
is your is your correct answer in the
radar space so that's a wild concept but
that's that is usually the way these
this Retreat needs to sort of about
this methodology is validated
yeah it was a question online I saw it
was about how how is the radar data
collected I think we look
yeah yeah I don't know why I'm doing it
that way
Bruce Sanders asked where does the radar
data come from you talk about a little
bit
how the data is collected
so the radar data I mean as you have a
radar deployed out of for example if we
have an x-ray radar what it's going to
do it the actual thing that it's the
actual uh signature that it's collecting
are way all right
our weight our face signals in the IQ
now those are the raw very raw data now
those pulses then have to be go ahead
they have to be processed into
interpretable radar Moments by
atmospheric scientists and those are
usually done at the actually NOAA will
distort that raw data and then they'll
do that processing on their on their
machines go to go ahead and process that
level one data up to level two data as
far as uh talk about how the the data is
collected through various deal campaigns
it's also collected as a standard
operational Network for nextrad you can
even take a mobile mobile radar put on a
truck and then you could go ahead and if
you're an example what the scan for
example if you want to do a something
like Vortex where you want to look at
wins inside a tornado you could take all
these different Radars put them in
trucks deploying them out near the
tornado and then you can try to go ahead
and do these wind retrievals out there
and that's what's been done for Vortex
and Vortex too
question yeah
so so with you so what are the ones uh
actually based upon the observation so
what if you were to stimulate a radar
inside the if you had a radar sitting
inside there and it's gonna collect it
you had the U and B value you would
actually it would the first one was what
would the radar record if you had the 2D
wind or 3D weight present at that point
then the other one was based off I I
it's based off of mass continuity so
basically assuming that masses gets
served throughout the volume
so what that does is that when you have
convergence
it will actually try when you have
converging error in a two-dimensional
space the air has been pushed upward or
downward depending on where you're
diverging and emerging so it's going to
resolve that as a physical rule
yeah that's actually why we we do it
very we the reason we do the weak
variational retrieval like that what we
call weak is because we know that
there's uncertainties in the
observations that can exceed that that
sometimes
that sometimes if we do a strong
variational retrieval it doesn't take it
to affect the potential absurdity in
your observations so we do this in a
more of a weak manner to try to take
that into account
question
so here are I've I've ever
at our I think there are some radar
packages I've although I'm not familiar
with ones that are the ones I'm familiar
with are in Python and and C
is the other way like elrose is written
in Cedar as a python wrapper around it
as far as data availability with next
red as long as you cite it's publicly
it's government public data you could
just use it so that's where radar data
it's anybody's available in it there's
no
there's no restriction on it outside of
you have to uh cite the data
is it's a it's a government service
provided to the public
now in Europe on the other hand that's a
different story because they privatize
their radar Network so you have to pay
that in the US says actually U.S is
actually the leader to make it publicly
available radar data available for the
public
understood
no uh
so we are not collaborating with
AccuWeather at any capacity as far as it
is basically I mean they they do
I mean I don't know what I get I don't
want to say too much about outside of it
is difficult to predict the weather
Beyond 10 days due to uh
initial conditions in your weight and
your weather forecast the sensitivity of
those models to the initial conditions
but really start to show itself in about
10 days and making a point forecast over
a region becomes incredibly difficult to
do so I would I would not trust a plague
forecast about 10 days I will not say
anything about specific products or
anything like that other than that
update
right NASA has actually used it for GPM
validation and revalidate validating
some of their Vertical Velocity
retrievals for uh GPM
Noah has not I think I don't think no
one doesn't really do multi-doppler
in anything so it mainly because the
computational expenses pretty high but
now with gpus being enabled and AGP that
was all the software has a caught up to
the technology so maybe in the next 10
years or something you know something
like this could you know if I have a
potential because I could do with a GPU
I could do this retrieval in about 20
seconds versus on a center computer it
takes several minutes for one time step
and if your parallel GPU system
eventually if we get to the point where
those become more standard and or like
no one or something they may be able to
provide a product like this
but that's still
that I think we're still years away from
that
and even then doing these a lot of times
a lot of times you do have to lose it
manual intervention for these retrievals
so that could it's a difficult that
would be a difficult
problem we usually use these more for
research
yes that is this act that I do may cause
function what I do mean with that it is
we are minimizing an error term to
determine an optional solution we're
minimizing the error what we call it the
deviation from observations from the
mass continuity equation because
Vertical Velocity or even
make ensure that the wind field doesn't
have noise in it by minimizing the
velocity of the wind field so it is
according to an air solution
so right now why about looking where I'm
involved in a project
called the community already it's it's a
it's a community oriented climate and
urban research studies called focusing
and we have that we're going to be
deploying it's a Doppler we deployed
some Doppler lidars that are that look
at various that are going to look at
winds and turbulence over about 30 meter
scales in the city so we're going to be
looking at doing some experiments with
those to let's see if we could get two
to 3D wins out of multiple Doppler
lidars and I want to be able to import
support for those into idda so that's
one of the next things I'm excited about
also I want to incorporate a complex
terrain as a as a boundary lower
boundary condition that's another
aspiration
they they'll fly up to well we measure
mode pressure but they'll fly up to
about
usually they'll hop in about what
probably 15 20 kilometers usually
no no yeah yeah that was it no that was
not a weather observation
no they would they'll just go up and
they'll pop yeah
and then actually if you find you can
find these Great White songs on the
ground and you're supposed to put them
in a mailbox but I don't know how many
people actually do that they just come
up as junk in the ground
yep
oh I have I thought so I've uh I did
play around a little bit with these at a
convolutional ostm and there are also
some research on this they're using
different types of good CNN networks to
uh try to predict the next time step
from the previous time step and try to
track these cells as they go through as
a way to do a quick Now cast because
they would speed up their that would
speed up our ability to Now cast storms
you could get to about a half hour now
which is actually decent considering uh
you could get Epi we still haven't gotta
passed about an hour
with that but I think they've gotten
about a half hour using CNN's
all right thank you thank you for
hosting me
my pleasure to talk today